على كل حال من القاهره مدير مرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
استاذ رامي لو طلعنا على سير عمليات
الانقاذ سواء في مناطق المعارضه او سيطره
النظام نعم مساء الخير طبعا عمليات
الانقاذ توقفت بشكل شبه كامل نتيجه عدم
وجود امكانيات لاستمرار الفرق الانقاص
بعمليه انتشال من هم تحت انقاض هذه
المباني وهو نقول بان هناك مئات الاسر لا
تزال تحت انقاذ المباني المهدمه التي يعني
سقطت على رؤوسهم والهزه الارتداديه زادت
الكارثه بانهيار مزيد من يعني من كان ان
كان الامكانيه للانقاذهم سقطت عليهم ايضا
هذه المباني نتحدث نحن يعني عن اعداد
كبيره من المفقودين نتحدث عن الان الجو
بارد بشكل كبير جدا نحن في الدفء الان وهم
الان تحت الارقام اذا ما كانوا على قيد
الحياه هل سيبقون على قيد الحياه ام
فارقون الحياه نتيجه هذا الجو البارد وهم
في تحتها هذا الركام الذي لا نعلم ما هو
مصيرهم هل الارض كم عدد الاطفال كم عدد
النساء كم عدد الرجال والشيوخ يعني وضع
كارثه وماساوي منذ الصباح نقول وضع كارثه
منذ الصباح نقول بان العدد مرشح للارتفاع
كنا نرفع العدد عشرات واذا به يرتفع
بالمئات تتحدث عن حتى اللحظه عن
1417 على الاقل حقيقه الامر هؤلاء الذين
توفوا
بنتيجه هذا الزلزال الكارثي الذي ضرب
الاراضي التركيه يعني امتد الى داخل
الاراضي السوريه ولكن اقول لك بداخل
الاراضي السوريه هو اصعب الاراضي التركيه
داخل تركيا يوجد فرق انقاذ فالاراضي
السوريه لا يوجد امكانيه امكانيات سواء
لدى النظام او لدى المعارضه من انقاذ يعني
المزيد من ابناء السوريين العراقيين تحت
الكوادر فرق الانقاذ
بشكل قطعي بشكل قطعي هناك نقص معدات هناك
يعني
لا يوجد فيها هناك لقص فيها بكل شيء نقص
بالمعدات نقص بالادويه بالنسبه للفرق
الطبيه فرق الطبيه لا تستطيع تامين هذه
الاعداد الكبيره سواء في مناطق النظام
وسواء في مناطق سيطره المعارضه سواء في
مناطق السيطره التركيه عندما نشاهد باحد
المشافي بعفرين ان هناك مئات الجرحى ومئات
والذين اصبحوا مئات الوفيات لاحقا هذا يدل
بان لا يوجد امكانيات لدى الفرق الطبيه
ذات الحاله ينطبق على حلقه ينطبق على
الاسارب الاقارب الذي التي لوحدها كان
فيها نحو 120 قتلوا نتيجه هذا الزلزال
وهدمت احياء بكاملها على رؤوس ساكنيها يا
حلب الشرقيه بلدات بلدات وصوره عده من ريف
حلب الجنوبي وصولا الى ريف حماه الشمالي
لم يكن احد يسمع بان هناك خسائر بشريه ان
هناك
تدمر تدمير في المنازل به لاحقا عصرا تاك
بوجود ضحايا في هذه البلدات المرتده
بالريف حلب الجنوبي الى ريف حماه الشمالي
اي ان الخسائر الى الان لم تحصى سواء لدى
النظام سواء لدى
المعارضه ارقام يعني ليست نهايه
رامي من يقوم بجهود الانقاذ ومساعده الناس
خصوصا اولئك الموجودين يعني او الموجودون
في العراء في ظل انخفاض درجات الحراره وهل
تم ايصال بعض المساعدات من تركيا الى
مناطق المعارضه عبر الحدود قد تكون بعض
المساعدات وصلت فعلا ولكن هذه المساعدات
التي وصلت تكفي هل هؤلاء الذين هم في
العراء اين سيباتون الان هل يوجد خيم تؤوي
هؤلاء حقيقه الامر هل يوجد منازل امنه
تاوي هؤلاء وحتى المدنيين السوريين الذين
لن تتهدم منازلهم بل تصدعتهم يفضلون
المبيت في العراق على ان يباتوا في هذه
المنازل المتصدعه خوفا من هزات ارتداديه
تؤدي الى سقوط المنازل على رؤوس من هم
فيها الاتي لذلك اقول بان المصارفيه كبيره
جدا من الحدود السوريه العراق التركيه في
اقصى شمال شرق سوريا وصولا الى الساحل
السوري كل هذه المناطق يوجد فيها حالات
خوف ورعب الكثير من الذين شعروا بالهزه
الارضيه اتصلوا باقاربهم في الخارج وقالوا
نحن نودعكم نحن نفارق الحياه كان هناك
حاله من الرعب حقيقه الامر حاله من الرعب
كبيره جدا عمت التراب السوري وتحديدا
المناطق التي تصدعت فيها المنازل حلب ثاني
اكبر المدن السوريه حجم الكارثه فيها هناك
تقديرات ربما لاعداد الاشخاص المحاصرين
خصوصا انه البعض يقول بانه الى الان لا
توجد ارقام حكوميه شفافه يمكن من خلالها
معرفه حقيقه الوضع على الارض
بشكل قطع لا توجد ارقام حكوميه شفافه ولا
توجد ارقام حقيقه لدى فصائل المعارضه كل
ارقام
يعني
حتى تتضارب في الارقام ما بين الجهات
العامله في مناطق
المعارض النظام يتحدث عن انه بامكانه
صباحا قال بانه بامكانه ان يساعد الذين هم
تدرسوا
الدول العربيه صراحه ناشطنا النظام قال
بانه ارسل فرس طبيا من دمشق درعا ومناطق
اخرى الى حلب يعني وتاخرت الفرق الطبيه
وحتى لو وصلت الفرق الطبيه هل يوجد لديهم
امكانيات
لمساعده كل هذه الاعداد الكبيره من الذين
يصيب ونتيجه هذا الزلزال لم يكن لديهم
امكانيات حقيقه الامر اعتقد بان هناك
اعداد كبيره من العارفين تحت الانقاذ هناك
شاهدنا مباني تسقط بالصوت والصوره في
احياء حلب بعد الزلزال نتيجه الهزات
الاقتصاديه شاهدنا صوره واحده مقطع مصور
واحد بينما لم نشاهد عشرات المباني الاخرى
التي هوت دون ان نشاهدها طيب هل صدر موقف
عن النظام امكانيات السماح بمرور مساعدات
الى المنظمات الانسانيه وان تتولى هي
تقديمها للمواطنين في اماكن سيطرته
يا سيدي الكريم اذا رفض النظام ان تدخل
هذه المساعدات بان النظام هو مساهم اساسي
باستمرار سقوط ضحايا هؤلاء السوريين الان
لا يحتاجون الى موقف سياسي يحتاجون الى حل
انساني يمنع سقوط المزيد من الضحايا في
المشافي سقوط المزيد او محاوله انقاذ من
هم الان تحت انقاذ المباني لذلك اقول بان
يجب ان نبعد السياسه الان فقط بالشق
الانساني سواء في منظره النظام او في
مناطق المعارضه او في مناطق السيطره
التركيه